>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Good morning everyone.
>> Good morning!
>> My name is Kahene Mohamad.
[phonetic] And welcome to
the Young Readers Center.
This morning we have a very
special program for you
with Everybody Wins: DC's Storytime.
We have author Christ Grabenstein,
who wrote "Mister Lemoncello's
Library" and a few others.
Have any of you been to the
Young Readers Center before?
One of you.
Have any of you been
to the library before?
Awesome. All right, does anybody
know how old this library is?
Does anybody -- do you know?
How old? [inaudible
response] Little bit older.
Let's count in years.
Does anyone maybe have a guess?
>> A million?
>> No, it's not a million years old.
[laughter]
>> You, right here.
>> Me?
>> Nope, so the library's
216 years old.
Does anyone know someone
that's that old?
[inaudible response] No.
>> No.
>> No. [laughing] The Young Readers
Center is only six years old, right?
So we are a very, very
new part of the library.
We don lots of programs like the one
you're taking part in this morning.
We're with authors and illustrators.
We also do the National
Book Festival.
Have any of you been to that?
Awesome. It's really awesome.
This year it'll be
September twenty fourth.
So make sure you all come down.
It's free and open to the public.
We also do a lot of
these author events
that you're a part
of, like this morning.
But I won't take up
any more of your time.
I'm going to introduce Chris,
who will take over from now.
--
>> Chris Grabenstein: Okay,
thank you [inaudible].
>> You're welcome.
>> You already had the slide here.
Okay, good.
Excellent.
I'm right there.
So you guys are in
the fifth grade right?
[inaudible response] Right?
That's my fifth grade class
picture up there on the screen.
Have you guys been able to figure
out which one of those kids I was
when I was in the fifth grade?
Anybody want to take a guess?
Yes?
[ Inaudible Response ]
The one with the red shirt?
>> No.
>> The blue?
[inaudible response] This one here?
Over here?
That's the teacher.
That's Misses Nays.
[phonetic] [inaudible
response] I don' t know.
Oh, here? No, his hair is blonde.
[inaudible response] Which one?
[inaudible response] This one?
That's a girl.
>> No. Right there.
>> This one?
>> Yes.
>> That's a girl too!
[laughter] It was 1965.
Things were a little strange back
there, but her hair is blonde.
What color's my hair?
>> Gray.
>> Black.
>> What color did my
hair used to be?
>> Black!
>> Black. It used to be black.
Yes!
>> Is it the one with the
blue shirt right there?
>> Blue shirt?
>> By the teacher.
>> Yeah, right there by the teacher.
He's got a receding hairline,
looks like he's going bald.
[laughter] No.
I didn't start going bald
until like 15-20 years ago.
That guy was going bald
in the fifth grade.
By the time we got to sixth grade
we all called him Chrome Dome.
Yes, which one was I?
[inaudible response] Black hair
with the glasses over here?
That's a very good guess.
By the teacher?
Oh, that's the same guy.
No, that's baldy there.
No, I'm going to give
you a little clue.
[laughter] When I was in the
fifth grade my eyesight was better
than it is today.
I did not wear glasses when
I was in the fifth grade.
Yes, back there.
>> Is it the one with the red shirt?
>> Red shirt?
That one right there?
The one who looks like
a little angel
who just fell down from heaven.
[inaudible response] Yeah,
that was me in the fifth grade.
[laughter] Yeah, that was me.
I don't think I've ever
looked that innocent again.
I show you that picture
for a couple reasons.
One; to prove before my
hair started turning gray --
thank you very much --
before I started going bald
up here I was actually the same age
as you guys and the fifth grade is
when I first really
started having fun writing.
I used to do these
little comic books.
My mom saved one.
I used to do these comic books
where I'd draw the pictures
and fill in the captions.
Any of you guys do that?
Anyone draw little comic --
oh, it's fun to do isn't it?
And give them to your
friends and stuff.
Do it during recess.
You'll get in a lot less
trouble than I used to get in.
And in fifth grade I won my
first writing award ever.
It was the Lions Club -- I grew
up in Signal Mountain, Tennessee
and we had a Lions Club
that had an essay contest
and I won that contest.
And the fifth grade is also when I
first started reading Mad Magazine.
Any of you guys still
read Mad Magazine?
Oh, [inaudible response]
yeah, Mad's got a TV show.
I got to work with Orlando Jones.
Yeah, and so that's where -- that
taught me a lot about the power
of words when I was in fifth grade
because I was the kind of kid
in the fifth grade that bullies
used to pick on and they would
like try to jump me and stuff.
And I got to the point where I
realized that I could use my wits
and my words to defeat them.
So Mad Magazine helped
me out a lot with that.
And then when I got into junior
high school -- there I am.
You can tell my mother used
to put a bowl on her -- hu?
[inaudible response] Yeah, I got
a B plus on this because we had
to write an essay; "What do you
want to be when you grow up?"
And then up to that point I
wanted to be a doctor or a lawyer
or an engineer like my father
was, but I had decided --
because in seventh grade I had a
teacher who wrote in the margins
of my paper, "You will make your
living as a writer someday."
And you know when a teacher tells
you something it has to be true
because all teachers take a solemn
vow to never lie to children.
Am I right teachers?
They remember that day.
It's a big day in their lives.
They raise their right hand and
say, "I will never lie to children."
So when that teacher told
me that it meant a lot to me
because you know your parents
can say stuff like you know, "Oh,
Chris you could be a writer!"
But they're your parents, they get
paid to say nice things about you.
So when a teacher told me this I
thought maybe I could be a writer.
So in eighth grade I
had to write this essay;
"What do you want to
be when you grow up?"
And I wrote, "But now my mind
wanders to a new thought,
to be a comedian or
a writer is my quest.
If this flops I would be
content to be a millionaire
and run Grabenstein's
Department Stores,
if I could ever fit
the name on the sign."
I got a B plus.
Anyone think I should've gotten
at least an A minus on that maybe?
A minus? Yeah, thank you mam.
[inaudible response]
Basically the same thing,
but I would have felt
better with the A minus.
I don't know why.
As a kid, I always did.
And then I went to high school --
and we had real long hair back then.
This is like -- hair down to here.
Yeah, we were all hippies back then.
And I had a really, really good
English teacher in ninth grade.
I went to Notre Dame Catholic High
School in Chattanooga, Tennessee,
which is where I grew up.
And I had this teacher named
Shack Van Duzen [phonetic]
and he's had two books dedicated
to him so far because he
like completely changed my life.
He introduced me to Mark
Twain and Shakespeare.
Yes sir.
[ Inaudible Question ]
Yeah, I never could do the dreads.
I just had the -- I
think I had down here --
like down -- really long hair.
We all had the long hair
back there in the 60s.
So this Shack Van Duzen was the
one who opened up my eyes on stuff
like Shakespeare and Mark
Twain and things like that.
So he was really influential.
And then I went to college and
I studied theater and journalism
at the University of
Tennessee in Knoxville.
Anybody here from Tennessee at all?
Anyone ever been to Tennessee?
That's where I grew
up was in Tennessee.
And then in 1979, before anybody
else in this room was born,
I moved to New York City and I
used to do improvisational comedy
with a troop in Greenwich Village.
We would just make up stories and
songs from audience suggestions
and we had a guy named
Bruce Willis in our troop.
He shaved his head and
moved to California.
We don't know what happened to him.
And the late Robin Williams --
that's him right there and there.
Whenever he was in town he
would jump up on stage with us
and we would make up
stories and songs.
So I was still like
having fun making things
up and creating things.
And then I wrote for the Muppets.
Do you guys ever watch the Muppets?
>> Yes!
>> Yeah! And then I did a made for
TV movie called The Christmas Gift,
starring John Denver, with a
buddy of mine from college.
We wrote this movie and it was
first on CBS way back in 1986
and it's still on television
every year.
I know this because my
mother calls up and tells me.
She says, "Chris, your
movie's going to be on;
three o'clock in the morning
on the Hallmark Channel."
I think my mother is the only
one still watching that movie.
And then I wrote radio
and television commercials
for almost 20 years.
That was my career for a while.
I wrote for KFC and Dr Pepper
and 7 Up and Burger King.
And guess who my first boss was when
I wrote Burger King commercials;
a guy named James Patterson.
Have any of you ever heard of him?
[inaudible response]
Oh, in the back.
Yeah! [laughing] Number
one, bestselling author
in the history of authors.
He's in the "Guinness
Book of World Records"
for having more number one
best sellers than any author.
So he was my first boss and now
we're starting to write books.
Now we flash forward ahead and
these are all the books I've written
that -- I guess they've all -- I
think are probably in the Library
of Congress now because -- yeah!
Yeah, I wrote a bunch of books.
And I write books now
with James Patterson.
We did the "Treasure Hunters" series
together and the "I Funny" series
and the "House of Robots."
And we -- this is a new book.
It's not even out yet.
It comes out in a couple of weeks.
Called, "Jackie Ha-Ha"
that he and I did.
But -- and I did these books
called, "The Island of Dr. Libris."
Yes, what's your question?
[inaudible question]
Did I draw the pictures?
No, someone else does
that because when I was
in fifth grade discovering that
I had a talent for writing,
some other fifth graders were
finding out they were pretty good
at drawing stuff and they went
and developed all the skills
to go with their talent.
So the illustrators -- there's a
lady named Laura Park in Chicago
who does the "I Funny" and there's
another lady in Canada that does
"Treasure Hunters"
and "House of Robots."
And "Jackie Ha-Ha" was done by
a pair of artists in France.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Question ]
Uh hu? [inaudible response] Uh hu.
[inaudible response]
Oh, that's good!
That's how we get started.
It all starts like that.
Yes? What were you going to say?
[inaudible question] What's that?
[inaudible question] My scary
books are these ones right here,
"The Haunted Mystery."
Let's call -- "Crossroads;"
all about a haunted tree
with a ghost trapped inside
a tree and lightening hits it
and the ghost gets out and
then these four are all scary.
And these "Daniel X" books
are kind of scary too.
What else -- oh yeah, then this is
the book I want to tell you guys
about today was "Escape from
Mr. Lemoncello's Library"
and that's the first book
with just my name on the cover
to become a New York
Times bestseller.
And it's been in the
top 10 now for 58 weeks
and then the sequel
just came out called,
"Mr. Lemoncello's Library Olympics."
And it's kind of fun for me to be
here at the Library of Congress
because it was one of the images
I used when I was writing the book
because Mr. Lemoncello -- have any
of you guys read that book yet?
"Escape from Mr. Lemoncello's
Library?"
You're going to get the second one.
Well, in the first book
we meet Mr. Lemoncello
who is this zany bazillionaire
who grew up in a town in Ohio,
where they bulldozed down
their public library.
And he decides to build
a new public library
and it is the most
amazing library ever.
It's like three stories tall with a
rotunda and there's holograms inside
and all sort -- because he made
all this money making games.
So he fills the whole library
with all sorts of games.
In fact I think I'll read
you a little bit from --
this is from the second book,
where we get to see a
little bit of the library.
And it's funny, we were just
walking around and I got to looking
at the rotunda and in Mr.
Lemoncello's library the rotunda is
lined with video screens so it can
change all the time and make it look
like the constellations of
the night sky or make it feel
like the whole library is
blasting off into outer space.
So in this, the second book, we get
to meet Mr. Lemoncello and he works
with a lady named Dr.
Yanina Zinchenko.
Dr. Yanina Zinchenko, the world
famous librarian dragged a lumpy
mail sack to the far end of the
rotunda reading room where her boss,
Luigi Lemoncello, was
flying up and down in front
of the three story
tall fiction bookcases.
"I'm looking for a good
book," said Mr. Lemoncello
as his hover ladder jerked
vertically then skittered sideways.
"But I'm not exactly sure
what I'm looking for."
The hover ladders were floating
platforms with handrails,
book baskets, and ski boot safety
locks that allowed you to float
up to retrieve any
book you wanted simply
by entering the book's column
number into a computerized keypad.
The system worked with the same
magnetic levitation technology used
in Germany and Japan
to propel bullet trains
with magnets instead of wheels.
"Perhaps I can be of
assistance," said Doctor Zinchenko
in her thick Russian accent.
"Do you have the code number?"
"No need!"
Mister Lemoncello said laughing.
"I wanted to test drive
our new browse function."
After several patrons had complained
of the hover ladder's demand
for a specific book code
eliminated the ability for patrons
to leisurely peruse the
shelves, the imagineers
at Mister Lemoncello's game
company had come up with a new,
and improved, hover ladders
which featured a browse button.
Once you pushed it the hover
ladder randomly flitted in front
of the shelves using advanced
biofeedback technology,
heart rate monitors, and complex
algorithms to figure out what sort
of story you might be interested in.
"But we have a very
important matter to discuss."
Doctor Zinchenko pointed
to the mail sack.
It was the size of an
overstuffed duffel bag.
"Oh dear! A VIM.
I don' t know if I have
the vigor for a VIM."
"We also have visitors!"
"Visitors and a VIM?
I'll deal with both as
soon as I finish browsing."
"Mister Lemoncello!"
bellowed a voice below.
He glanced down and saw a
properly dressed lady flanked
by six other very properly
dressed ladies
and one properly dressed
man in a bowtie.
"I'll be right with you!"
shouted Mister Lemoncello
as his hover ladder careened
across the wall of books like an
out of control ping pong ball.
"I'm busy browsing."
"My name is Susanna Chiltington,"
the lady said operatically.
"Misses Susana Willaby
[phonetic] Chiltington."
"Hello Susana.
Don't you cry for me.
The doctors say they can easily
remove the banjo on my knee."
Misses Chiltington wasn't amused.
"Perhaps you've heard of
my brother," she said.
"The head librarian for
the Library of Congress;
James F Willaby the third."
"What happened to the first two?"
"I beg your pardon?"
"Never mind.
I am finished browsing.
Pull me down 'Captain
Underpants.'" [laughter]
So Mister Willaby is not
really the head librarian here.
So that is the kind of zany place
that Mister Lemoncello's Library is
and it's just filled with
all sorts of whacky stuff.
Yes sir? [inaudible
question] What's that?
[inaudible question] I read
some other of my books.
Yeah. We're talking
about this one mostly
because this one has
been very popular.
It's up in that New York Times
Best Seller, it's got a lot
of nice reviews everywhere,
and Amazon picked it as one
of their favorite books, and
it won an LA "A Notable."
But most importantly,
Nickelodeon might turn it
into a movie this year.
I know, that's what I said too.
[excited noise] Might happen.
So it might happen this year.
And it's been nominated
for 39 now --
they said 36, but I think California
and New Jersey have been
added -- state book awards.
And it's won 10 of them already.
So this has been a
lot of fun for me.
But oh -- let's see what was I
going to say -- oh, this is --
people always ask me like,
"How did you get an idea?
How do you get ideas for stories?"
So I got the whole idea for "Escape
from Mister Lemoncello's Library"
when I was visiting that
library right there.
That's PS10 in Brooklyn, New York.
Have you ever been to
Brooklyn, New York?
That's what all the schools in
Brooklyn, New York look like.
They're like four stories tall,
made out of red brick,
been there since 1932.
Forget about it.
That's what they look like.
So I went up and I said,
"Hey, nothing out of the
out of the ordinary
here," because it --
as a writer, if you guys
want to write stories,
just look for something that's a
little bit out of the ordinary,
a little bit out of whack because
nobody likes to read nice stories
about nice people having a nice day
or ordinary people doing ordinary
things in an ordinary way.
So I said, "It's another
ordinary school."
But then they said,
"Come on upstairs
and meet the kids in our library."
And this was the library
in that school.
It had murals everywhere,
solid oak bookcases filled
with books, computers.
Does that library look like
it belongs in that building?
>> No.
>> Not to me it didn't.
It looked a little too new.
So I went up to the librarian,
Misses McKreena [phonetic] there
and I said, "How did you
guys get this really cool,
brand new library?"
And she said, "A very generous
millionaire donated it to us."
So that day on the subway
ride home I wrote down,
"What if a very generous,
and somewhat looney,
bazillionaire donated a library
to the town where he grew up?"
And that's how all
stories get started.
You just have to -- can you guys
all stroke your chins like this?
Look around and see something
a little bit under --
like, "Oh, what's that half
a fireplace over there?
What if that fireplace
was where the Library
of Congress kept Santa Clause
all stored up in the winter
and in the summer, except in
December when he had to --
but he had to live in that little
box over there and they rolled him
around to different rooms?"
And you start thinking like that.
That's how you can start
making up some stories.
Oh, and it's been kind of fun -- oh,
and I got the idea for the kid in it
because you know what's
really kind of neat?
Is you can take aspects of your own
life and turn them into stories.
So this is me, right there.
That was me when I was a little kid.
I got two big brothers
and two young brothers.
My mother had five
boys in seven years.
We think she was trying
to have a girl.
And I had these two big brothers
who I could never beat at anything.
But they -- like my brother, Jeff
[assumed spelling] over here,
he was like this genus kid and he
would go to school and taka test,
like one of those IQ brain tests,
and he'd get like a 99 on it.
And I remember the teachers
and the principals came home
and said, "Oh, Jeff is a genius.
He should skip three or four grades.
He should go right to high school."
And I would take the exact same
test the next year and get a 96
and they'd go, "Yeah, he's
smart, but he's no Jeff."
So I always had like these
big brothers I couldn't beat
at anything except when
we played board games.
And since there was like five of
us we played a lot of board games.
[inaudible comments] You
guys ever play "Sorry?"
[inaudible replies] There is
no better feeling in the world
than landing your pawn
on the same space
as your big brother
and saying, "Sorry!"
and sending him all the
way back to the beginning.
So I took that remembrance I
had, that memory I had that --
of how good it felt to beat my
brothers [laughing] at games
and so the hero of my story, "Escape
from Mister Lemoncello's Library,"
is this kid named Kyle who more
than anything loves playing
games and loves to win.
So I got that from there.
Oh, and this is the pictures I used
when I was designing my own library.
And now I can say,
"I've been there."
There's the Library of Congress.
There we go.
And this is the bank that was in
the town I grew up in; Buffalo,
New York, when I was a kid.
So I said that he took
an old bank building
and he turned the --
it into a library.
And this is a parking garage at
a library somewhere in Kansas
where they have -- the
outside looks like bookshelves.
So I did all that and I
-- so that's another way.
When you're writing you
just kind of look for things
and put them together
and use your imagination
and make up your own library.
So now there's a new
book, the sequel --
I think you guys are all
getting a copy of this one,
which sounds pretty cool
-- that just came out.
And -- oh -- this is a little
book trailer we did about that.
Greetings.
This is so much fun writing.
[ Music ]
To the book store!
My name is Chris Grabenstein and I'm
an author and my new book is called,
"Mister Lemoncello's
Library Olympics."
It's a sequel to "Escape from
Mister Lemoncello's Library."
And in this book Mister Lemoncello
is hosting the first ever
library Olympics.
Whoever can win the most metals
in 12 games will be crowned the
True Champion of the Library.
[music] Good story.
I love challenging my mind
and giving it some exercise.
>> [grunting] Push it out.
[grunting] One more!
[grunting]
>> [inaudible] so heavy.
So many questions in here.
[inaudible] move it.
And I also love puzzles.
Does anybody know a seven
letter word for fun?
>> Reading!
>> Thank you.
And so I wrote "Mister
Lemoncello's Library Olympics"
as a puzzle mystery because
I can solve the riddle
of the book before the
characters inside the story do.
And that makes reading
a lot more fun.
As the games continue certain
books start disappearing
because certain people don't
like what's inside those
books; a real cliffhanger.
I've always been a big
believer in the First Amendment;
everyone should be able to read
whatever books are available
to them, of course with
parental supervision.
And so in this book Mister
Lemoncello joins the cause.
It's always good to train
my body and my brain
by reading [inaudible] Lemoncello
[inaudible] And my advice
to aspiring writers is the same
thing that most authors give, "Read,
read, read, write, write, write.
You get better the more you practice
and you will have the stuff
to be true champions."
[ Music ]
Ah, so that was easy.
Yeah! It's fun to do
and I sweat a lot.
I -- so I got the idea for the
sequel from a fifth grader,
a guy like you, who read the first
book and he said, "I bet kids all
over the country are
going to complain
that they didn't get a chance
to compete in the first game
and they might want
to have a rematch."
And that's how the whole idea of
the library Olympics got started.
The kids from all over America
will come and compete in 12 games.
So now I thought we might play a
few reading Olympic games here.
You guys ready to play some games?
>> Yes.
>> All right.
I'm going to put some clues up here
and let's see if you guys can --
let's see, what's the first one.
Can you name these
famous children's books?
You guys ready?
>> "One Fish, Two Fish,
Red Fish, Blue Fish!"
>> Oh, you got that one.
Okay, here comes another one.
Oh, this one's a little hard.
>> Oh, [inaudible]
"Charlotte's Web!"
>> Got it.
Perfect. Good.
That's the hardest one.
[laughing] That's good.
Now this one's -- you've got to
think about this one for a second.
[inaudible] Money and an island.
What's another word for money?
>> "Treasure Island!"
>> Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding!
All right, here --
oh, this one's easy.
[ Inaudible Answers ]
"The Very Hungry Caterpillar."
All right, good.
Oh --
>> "Charlie and the
Chocolate Factory!"
Chocolate Factory."
Good, good, good!
All right, now you have
to finish the title.
You've got to fill
in the blank on this.
These are the kind of Olympic
competitions you're going to find
in this book you're
going to read here.
All right, bud nut --
>> Buddy!
>> Boom! Got it!
The blank rabbit.
>> The rabbits!
>> The what?
>> The rabbits.
>> The rabbit rabbit?
No, that would be redundant.
The what? [inaudible]
The Velveeta rabbit!
No, I mean "The Velveteen Rabbit."
It's a cheesy book.
Anyhow, all right, here we go.
Curious --
>> George!
>> Yeah, everybody knows that one.
Is there one more?
Yes, there is.
Cloudy with a --
>> Chance of meatballs!
>> Meatballs!
All right, okay now -- oh, I think
I need two of you to come up here.
Oh, yeah let's see, we're
going to have a head
to head competition here.
Yes mam, you come up here.
And I need you.
Come on up here.
All right.
I'm going to show you a little
what we call a REBUS puzzle,
where you take pictures
and the letters and things
and you see if you can work it out.
Here's a pen for you and you got
a little piece of paper there.
You can work it out.
You can look at each other's work.
Okay, here comes the puzzle.
You ready?
>> Yeah.
>> Lion plus bear plus
carry minus one minus car.
Can you name this intellectual --
this fortress of intellectual
freedom.
So write down all the letters
first would be my suggestion --
of lion, bear, and carry.
You can do it too.
LION. [laughs] Bear; BE -- don't
have to worry about the puzzle.
BEAR and carry; CARRY.
And now the puzzle
says, "Take away one."
So take out ONE.
Cross out ONE.
[affirmative noises]
O, there's an N,
and E. And also car, which is CAR.
Take out a CAR.
What letters do you have left?
[inaudible answer]
You got it already!
She figured it out down here.
She wasn't even on the board.
Library! Oh, let's give
everybody a round of applause.
[applause] Good job you guys.
[cheering] All right, you got it.
Library, LIBRARY, library.
That's good.
The end is gone.
There we go.
She's got it.
Excellent.
Thank you guys.
Sit on down.
Is there another game up here?
Oh, one more game.
One more game here.
Can you name this fictional
character?
character here?
Yes? [inaudible question]
What's that?
Can you get a hint?
Well, he looks like
he's got a lot of hair.
So I'd call him kind of a hairy guy.
>> Big foot.
>> And he looks like
he's making pottery.
[inaudible answer] So he's a
hairy guy who makes pottery.
>> Harry Potter!
You got it!
All right, it is Harry
Potter ladies and gentlemen.
[laughing] That is a hairy potter.
[inaudible] Well, you guys did very
good and it's a good thing you did
because when you read this
book you're going to find
out that you would be up against
some of the toughest competition
in the entire country, including
there's this one girl named Marjorie
Moldower [phonetic] who's very scary
smart and she knows her way around.
But I think you guys would
compete just fine against it.
Oh, here's a question I
get asked all the time.
People say, "Why did you name
your character Mister Lemoncello?"
And first of all, I know it's a
beverage that many teachers enjoy,
but the real reason I wrote --
called it Mister Lemoncello is
because when I wrote the first
"Escape from Mister Lemoncello's
Library" book I made a list
of all the reasons we
might need public libraries
because everybody says you know,
"I just got an iPhone" or "an iPad.
I can look up anything.
I can read anything.
Why do I still need a library?"
So when I wrote the book
I consciously set out
and made a list like, "Okay,
why do we still need public
libraries especially?"
And at the top of my personal list
was that libraries are a great place
for immigrants, newly arrived in
this country, to keep in touch
with their old country and find
out about their new country
and that meant a lot to
me because my grandmother
and grandfather both escaped from
Greece like back in the 1920s.
The Turks burnt down their village
and my grandmother was
a 17 year old girl --
so not too much older
than you guys here --
and she was put on a boat
with a bunch of refugees
to be taken somewhere safe,
but the boat that she was put
on had a cholera epidemic,
which can kill people.
And so they said, "No
one is leaving this boat.
You're going to all
go back to Greece.
We're sorry."
And my grandmother said,
"I'm not going back."
So in the middle of the night
when the moon was blocked
by clouds she climbed down an
anchor rope, swam to shore,
met up with all these
other refugees,
made her way across
Europe, got on another boat,
somehow got to Ellis Island, made it
into America, went to Canton, Ohio,
and my mom was the first one
of her family born in America.
And she said when she was a kid
she promised herself she would read
every single book in the
Canton, Ohio Public Library
because that would make
her more of an American.
So that's a real long
way of telling you
that I actually named him
Mister Lemoncello in honor
of my Greek grandmother, whose last
name was Lemonopolis, [phonetic]
and because if she had not
climbed down an anchor rope
when she was 17 years
old I would not be
in New York City making
up silly stories today.
Yes? [inaudible question]
That disease cholera, right?
Was on that boat and that
makes people really sick
and can even kill people.
So the British sailors
said, "You cannot leave.
Yes?
>> We talked about that in class.
>> Did you learn about
that cholera epidemic?
Yes, so it's like -- yeah, I
always have a soft spot when I read
about refugees in the
news and stuff.
I always remember that most every --
my grandparents were refugees
themselves at one point.
Oh, knowledge not shared
remains unknown.
That's Mister Lemoncello's
big motto.
He runs his whole library on
that, that a library is a place
where everybody can
learn everything.
It's free and open to everyone.
And so in that spirit there is
a hidden puzzle in this book
that you guys are going to get and
there's going to be a prize given
to whoever -- if you answer
the hidden puzzle correctly
and send me an email about it
and if you get the correct answer
your name will be entered into --
we'll put it in a big goldfish bowl
or something and we're going to pull
out one winner on January fifth,
2017 who will get two libraries
of books; two copies of every
book I've ever written for kids,
two copies of every book my
friends can grab at Random House.
We did this with the first book.
There was another hidden one in that
and we gave away 80 pounds of books.
So the idea is that you will
keep one library for yourself
and then donate another one to your
favorite school or public library.
But since you guys were nice
enough to come here I'm going
to read you the clue -- the riddle.
This is what's in the book.
Are the games really over?
Of course not.
Here's one final puzzle.
20 things you've just read --
20 things Mister Lemoncello said
were once not allowed to be read
because of what other people said.
Can you find them all?
If so, send an email with your list
to author@chrisgrabenstein.com.
But since you guys are
here today I'm going
to give you a bonus clue --
a bonus clue that might
send you on the right track.
All right, here we go.
Where is it?
Here we go; Mister Lemoncello
has a wild imagination.
He drops some famous titles into his
conversation; like you heard him say
"Captain Underpants" in
that little thing he said.
He does that a lot in this book.
He did it 20 times while
speaking in this book.
So why don't you go back
and take another look.
Find what they have in
common if you want to win
and when you think you've got
it just send your answer in.
So pay very close attention
to all the book titles he puts
into his conversation
when you read the book.
All right, I thought
I would stop and see
if you guys had any questions
you want to ask me about reading,
writing, and life in general.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Question ]
Sometimes.
In my book, "The Island
of Dr. Libris" here?
That's that I took -- there's a
boy with a really big imagination
and any book he reads, the
characters from that book come
to life out on an island
in the middle of a lake.
So that's about the only one
where I've taken characters
from other books.
And so people like --
Robin Hood is out there
and the Three Musketeers
and people like that.
Yes Mam.
[ Inaudible Question ]
Do all my stories have pictures?
No, most of my storybooks
are chapter books.
The ones I do with James
Patterson, like "Treasure Hunters"
and "I Funny" and "House
of Robots" those have a lot
of illustrations in them.
And I have a new book coming
out in October called,
"Welcome to Wonderland:
Home Sweet Motel."
It's going to have a lot
of pictures in it too.
Yes mam.
>> Do you like reading [inaudible]?
>> Yes I do!
I love it!
Do you like it?
Yeah, if I find the right books.
I've got to be honest with you guys.
I'm still a little bit of what
they call a reluctant reader
and if I pick up a book and it's
boring I'll put it right back down.
That just means it's not
the right book for me.
So what you've got to do is get
your teachers and your librarians
and everybody to help you find
books that are right for you
because I don't think it's
-- because I still get bored,
but I love like books like there's
this guy named Steve Sheinkin
who writes nonfiction as
if it was an action movie
and I'm reading a book of his
about Benedict Arnold right
now that's incredible.
And I like "Bud, Not Buddy."
You guys read that one yet,
by Christopher Paul Curtis?
It's a lot -- oh, it's
very exciting.
I just saw it in the other room.
So yeah, you can find
the right books.
I love reading and I love writing.
I've been doing this since
fifth grade and it's wonderful
if you can find something
in life that you love to do
and it's even better if
somebody will pay you to do it.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Question ]
What's that?
>> Have you ever written
your own book?
>> Oh, I've -- most of these
books are written just by me.
And then when James Patterson
and I work together we
sort of -- we collaborate.
So we -- that means
we work together.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Question ]
-- "Escape from Mister Lemoncello's
Library" is available wherever fine
books are sold.
You can find it all over the place.
I bet you they probably have
it in your school library
and you guys are all getting a
copy of the second book today.
>> Oh!
>> Yeah, I think they're going
to be autographed copies too.
[excited noise] I think so.
Yes? [inaudible question] I
think -- I'm not going to.
I think this nice lady back
here [laughing] is going
to let you have one of my books.
These two nice ladies there have
got the books for all you guys.
So that's kind of cool.
I like this.
Who else has a question?
Yes? [inaudible question] Yes.
[inaudible question] This
is my library right here,
the Library of Congress.
Actually it's all our libraries
in some way because this is owned
by the people of the
United States of America.
So yes, this is my library,
but it's also your library too.
[inaudible] Yes?
[ Inaudible Question ]
What they do -- what they --
they take the rights to a story
and then they take my
book -- my story --
and then give it to someone who's
more skilled at writing screenplays,
because that's really hard.
You guys have seen movies right?
From books?
You guys like the "Harry
Potter" books?
>> Yes!
>> Did you see the
"Harry Potter" movies?
>> Yes!
>> There's a lot of
stuff missing right?
They -- because you have
to like cut, cut, cut,
cut down when you make a movie.
So they took my book and they've
given it to a screenplay writer
and I've not seen the screenplay
yet so I have no idea [laughing]
what the movie might look like.
I might be crying, I might
be laughing, we'll see.
Yes? [inaudible question]
Why didn't I name it my name?
Because I think Lemoncello
is more fun
because it has alliteration
going, like;
"Mister Lemoncello's Library"
has all those L sounds.
And it just sounds zanier.
There's something about
Lemoncello's library.
It sounds more fun than
Mister Grabenstein's library.
That sounds like it
should be a hardware store.
I don't know.
How much -- are we doing okay?
>> We're doing good.
>> All right, good.
Yes, my friend the question man.
I'm going to call you Question Man.
[ Inaudible Question ]
I don't think I can do that,
but I'm not sure if that's part
of the plan today or not.
We'll ask somebody and come back.
Yeah, I got to look
around a little earlier.
Anybody else have a
question they want to -- Yes?
>> How can you do that?
>> How did I do this?
I worked backwards.
Whenever you are trying to
write a puzzle or a mystery --
see everyone -- I was asked this
last night at a bookstore I was at,
like, "How'd you come up
with all these riddles?
How'd you come up with
all these games?"
It's because I knew what I
wanted the answer to be, right?
So I knew that I wanted the
answer to be "library" so I said,
"Well, what can I put together?
What letters can I jumble together
and take some letters
away to equal library?"
And that's how I ended up with that.
So it's a lot easier
to write puzzles
if you know what you
want the answer to be.
Yes Question Mark?
[ Inaudible Question ]
We played all the games.
Read the book.
The book is filled with games
for you to compete with --
along with the people
inside the story.
So there will be more games.
All right, well this
has been fun for me.
Thank you guys for coming
in today and enjoy the book
and I hope you all solve
that hidden riddle.
Thank you!
>> Thank you Chris.
We just want to thank
Everybody Wins DC again
and also Walker Jones
Educational Campus.
Thank you all for coming out.
I hope you all had a fun time.
Thank you.
You all have a good day.
[ Cheering ]